الى لاهاي حيث يعقد اكثر من 600 محام من
دول مختلفه في العالم اجتماعين منفصلين مع
كل من مكتب المدعي العام وقسم الضحايا
التابعين للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه وسيقدم
الفريق القانوني ادله جديده ويبحث الشكوى
المقدمه حاليا ضد اسرائيل بشان جرائم
الاباده والتطهير العرقي التي يرتكبها
الاحتلال في قطاع غزه وياتي اجتماع الفريق
القانوني الدولي في المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه عشيه نطق محكمه العدل الدوليه
بقرارها بشان قضيه اتهام اسرائيل بجرائم
اباده جماعيه والمقدمه من دوله جنوب
افريقيا معنا من امام مقر محكمه الجنايات
الدوليه في لاهاي مراسلنا نور الدين
بوزيان نور الدين ما هو المنتظر من هذه
الاجتماعات يبدو سلمى بان شيئا ما ربما
سيعلن عنه بعد قليل في هذا المؤتمر الصحفي
الذي نترقبه بعد بين دقيقه واخرى حيث ان
الوفد وفد المحامين الوفد الدولي للمحامين
يوجد داخل هذه البنايه لعقد اجتماعين
اجتماع مع مكتب المدعي العام
للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه وايضا اجتماع مع
مكتب الضحايا لماذا نقول هذا لان الملفات
التي حملها الثلاثي اي المحامون الثلاثه
الذين دخلوا صباح اليوم تقريبا منذ حوالي
ثلاث ساعات بل وازيد بقليل حملوا ملفات
ثقيله عن هذه الملفات يمكن القول بان كل
عنوان كل مكان كل جهه استهدفها الجيش
الاسرائيلي جاء بها المحامون بوثائق وادله
وقرائن يتعلق الامر مثلا باستهداف
المدنيين وله صفحات مخصصه ايضا استهداف
مثلا المشافي والمستشفيات الاطفال وجهات
اخرى من المدنيين الحديث في الحقيقه سلمى
هو
عن القانون الاساسي من نظام هذه المحكمه
الذي يكرس ما يسمى
با اثبات عمل اثبات يعني جريمه حرب كما
قال رئيس
الوفد المحامين الذي تحدث الينا عشيه
وصوله الى هذه المحكمه عند ما قال بان
الان اركان التهم التي موجهه لاسرائيل
وللمسؤولين الاسرائيليين باتت ثابته طبعا
يجب ان نعرف ايضا بان المطلوب من هذه
المداولات ان صح التعبير اذكر بان هذا
ثالث اجتماع للوفد الخاص بال المحامين
الدوليين الذي رفع دعوه ضد اسرائيل هو
ثالث منذ نوفمبر وهذا يعني بان شيئ ما
يعني تحقق في هذه المداولات والامر يتعلق
الان باقناع هذه المحكمه خلفي بضروره
استصدار يعني مذكرات جلب
للمتهمين الرئيسيين بهذه الاباده التي
يشهدها العالم من بينهم نتنياهو وايضا
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي ورئيس هيئه
الاركان هذه هي الاسماء المتداوله علينا
ان ننتظر سلمى لمعرفه ربما بعد قليل ماذا
حصل عليه الوفد الدولي للمحامين اليوم من
خلال محادثاته ذكر فقط بان ربما ما يؤشر
الى ان الاشياء تطورت ايجابيا هو ان
الاجتماع السابق كان احد المحامين تحدث
بان هناك اختراق في هذه المداولات اذكر
بان هناك كانت انتقادات واضحه من قبل
الوفد وفد المحامين الدوليين للمدعي العام
الذي كما قيل لنا بانه مثلا يبطئ عمليه
التحقيق قيل لنا بانه يتصرف بطريقتين مثلا
زار الضحايا او المتضررين الاسرائيليين
مما حدث ولم يذهب الى مثلا الى السكان
الفلسطينيين فهناك نوع من الاتهامات وربما
التحدي الاكبر في هذا هذه المداولات اليوم
هو ماذا سيحدث غدا في محكمه العد الدوليه
وكيف سينعكس ايجابا على ما يقوم به الوفد
المحامين شكرا لك من امام مقر محكمه
الجنايات الدوليه في لهاي مراسلنا نور
الدين بوزيان